okay I'm back i streamed earlier today
but I am back for a relatively quick
stream earlier today was a chess calm
arena Kings tournament which I played in
and I did decently I played some pretty
strong players play the error camps in
one game which I actually have right
here which I was just going over forgot
my opening preparation and I just got
completely crushed so I'm gonna keep the
stream hopefully more instructive and I
see desert booj is already in the chat I
hosted him earlier with probably a
record number of viewers for him he was
totally unprepared playing atomic chess
it's fun to watch yeah I've been making
an effort to like host people with lower
viewer accounts just share some love and
actually today was my first time
streaming a tournament on chess comm I
think ever so is a different experience
to Lee chess but it seems same kind of
format as Lee chess but there were
differences I was trying to get used to
so anyway I'm gonna keep this as a
relatively instructive stream and I want
to focus on just teaching like fewer
questions actually one of the reasons
why I'm doing this is because I was
getting questions earlier today and I
was playing I was so hard to play and
answer questions
I see Braden's back I know he had
questions earlier which I don't even
remember what they were and I don't
think I answered all of them
yeah Hiro missed the stream earlier but
it's good to see heroes in the chat it
was kind of unplanned I found about I
found out about it last night and
decided to to stream it and oh and I
forgot by the way um if you guys want to
help me you can vote for me on the
Twitter poll I think I have a move on
command hopefully this works I haven't
tested it yet
type in vote it'll take you to the link
of the Twitter
poll and there's money on the line I
think there's a money prize of like $25
so I would be extremely grateful for any
types of votes I could get hello to var
14 609 welcome and Braden saying I
finally made it to chess excellence
someone accused me of cheating sometimes
that's the best compliment if someone
thinks you're using an engine but you
actually just played good moves
that's I think a milestone in most
people's chest careers I'm trying to
think if I've ever actually been accused
of using an engine because I've played
like tournament games before where like
all my moves have matched the engine but
I don't think anyone's ever accused me
as some of those games have been the
best games I've ever played I have to
dig those up those would be interesting
to show anyway if you guys have any
questions feel free just shoot them at
me it can be opening related I
specialize in opening preparations so if
you're looking for recommendations if
you're wondering what to do against the
certain variation if you want me to look
at one of your games even I want to
provide as most or as much value as I
can to whoever's watching no one is in
the chat maybe they're all voting for me
on Twitter right now that's nice I'm
gonna take a look at this Eric Hanson
game I can I flip the board laughs there
we go can you recommend a book on
openings a book on openings I mean okay
books on opening are probably the most
popular type of chest book because
there's a book for literally every
single opening you can think of there is
even a book called unorthodox openings
which talks about all the openings that
no one ever plays Nolita org in title oh
no I forgot to change the title the
chest calm stream oh and the chest calm
stream
I changed the community let me remove
that
I completely forgot HS org so it's
probably not showing up so if I update
on this window is really small me and
large this for a moment
updated okay hopefully that works I
don't want it to block like the thing I
only have one monitor so it's hard to
like move stuff around now I have to go
back to the chat chat these are the few
tabs here we go oh I can have both
communities simultaneously oh that's
cool how do you use stuffy I don't
understand that question
but yeah Ivar I think Braden is asking a
good follow up question is like I asked
about like a specific opening if you
want opening books in general I don't
know if I can think of any off the top
of my head I mean there's repertory
books and it depends on your level too
so if you're I mean if you're below like
1500 I would recommend don't put too
much focus on openings I mean it's
something you can study but I mean
tactics and strategy middle game
planning is far more important and I see
the questions are coming in I do have a
question for faith though because I I
was in the Chess Khan community I guess
I'll add that back in if they're ok with
that
is there a chess community oh there is
ok maybe that's new so updates hopefully
I'm not like separating the stream into
like multiple multiple things but I see
the titles changed so that's good ok um
chess su xxx I'm doing well thanks for
asking
I see I'm getting questions what I'll do
is I have a note
document.ready hopefully that's
displaying okay I'm just gonna start
pasting questions I'm getting so I don't
forget them and maybe we can just go in
order how do you study endgame as a 1500
player that's a good question it is more
or less important or more or less a
chess question but here it goes there's
a dude much higher rated than me helping
me helping my chest out I was reading
this from Monday and one he got really
frustrated
ouch how are you supposed to react to it
that's a difficult way that's just a
difficult situation to be in when your
opponent is like I'm reacting
emotionally if I was in that situation I
wouldn't say anything I would not try to
talk to him especially right away like
let him cool down he's much higher rated
and he's helping you out and he like
threw a tantrum like let them cool down
it's one of those things where like
they're so emotional in the moment that
you have to give them their own space
and then come back to them and just like
it's part of the game like losing to
lower rated opponent's it's part of the
game and most players aren't mature
enough to know that but if they aren't I
mean they they have to learn their
lesson let's go back to this question
about end games for a 1500 player
because for that I mean one thing I can
recommend is like build up and gain
theory knowledge so like learn all these
theoretical positions and there's
there's a few books I can recommend
there's a book by by Jeremy Schulman
what is that Jeremy's so many thing game
if you type in Jeremy someone I'm game
into Google it's called a Simmons
complete endgame course from beginner to
master I assume
and it covers and games for like all
rating levels but it's a good book to
work through and kind of build
foundational knowledge and then it gets
more difficult as you progress through
the book the other endgame book was
other endgame book I was thinking of dev
rescue my ID game manual but that's
probably not aimed for a 1500 player
there's some good you could youtube
content and games I know John
Bartholomew has like a bunch of like
basic videos I would suggest going
through those st. Louis chess club they
have an endgame lecture video every week
pretty much so you can go back in their
archives I think I I've done at least a
handful of those so I know okay I see if
comment from bar who's been watching
some of my videos if I can't answer all
of the questions hopefully someone in
the chat can can provide answers as well
for Korean knife see he's asking about
one be for let's make a new chapter here
I'm gonna call it how to crush one
before there's actually a very specific
reason why before is not popular I'll
move one its playable but at higher
levels there's just kind of a known I
want to call it refutation but I know in
response for back it's to play e5 and
most stronger players will know this but
maybe lesser experienced players won't
know this as black you can you can
actually get away with taking the baton
taking on before is the best move and it
seems unusual because you're trading a
center pawn for a winged pawn but the
the justification is that black is just
accelerating development and the bishop
on e5 can be used to gain tempo and
accelerate further development like box
already to are already ready to castle
ready to play moves like d5 see 596 so
I've had games in this position
nine of three looks like a natural move
say castle say e3 d5 and from the black
side I don't know too much beyond this I
just know that it like black likes to
play see 596 and then this Bishop
usually retreats to to a better diagonal
the space and development is very
comfortable for black so yeah at the
higher levels it's pretty important to
have responses against these lesser
common openings like it's good to have a
response against before good to have a
response against b3 and these open these
are lines that you won't run into too
often but it's just good to have
something in your back pocket because
you don't want to be thinking on move
one if your opponent plays b4 or b3 so
anyway um I might be falling behind
Brayton is asking do it do I have a
hundred n games you should know I do not
have that book and if you guys are gonna
ask me for book recommendation questions
I'm properly not the person to ask but I
will share a good resource like if
you're looking for a reputable player
for to recommend books there is this
website it's also a podcast perpetual
chess pod calm perpetual chess podcast
with Ben Jonson and he has a page on his
site which are which is just like a
extensive list of book recommendations
so I'm just gonna share that in the chat
because it's pretty nice oh and thank
you for modding I don't even know what I
missed but thanks mods for doing your
job a perpetual chess podcast if you
want book recommendations check out that
list zgr what's your plan when you face
the Kings Indian defense do you go for
London set up so if you're asking about
what I do when I play against King's
Indian I can gladly show
one one plus one is asking about two a
three oh I guess polish um d5 just grab
the center Bishop b2 Bishop d6 actually
this is interesting can wipe layout for
take two Queen h4
these lines are tricky Bishop g2 Queen
f4 Queen f4 threatening mate I'm just
following the one master game it had
this position I'm just gonna get a quick
answer and like check stockfish I think
black is winning somehow with a bishop
on d6 because Bishop g2 best move but we
can just take on each - King neckline
yeah I remember that it's like it's
tricky if you if you're not using a
computer is to get an advantage here for
black but neither six I guess is a team
of ideas of Knight g4 and if white takes
here it's just own ie 4 even whoo 94
bishop take e4 this pawn so strong
bishop h3 ideas too are coming those
Knights actually trapped okay so the
whole lines guide for for the white side
and here it okay it's pleasant for black
okay let me go to that Kings Indian
question because I do want to kind of
share what I like my strategy because
that's something I've had trouble with
for a long time until only maybe a year
or two ago so I'm gonna say London
versus King team defense I will also
share the link to the study because I
created a study just for answering
viewer questions so if you guys want to
follow along or like look deeper into
any analysis I just shared the link in
the chat anyway Kings Indian I play
what's called the Barry attack
where it starts off as a London and then
when they play g6 I like to play Knight
c3 and if you haven't followed too many
of my streams maybe you haven't seen
games in this but I play this a lot
online in half the time it transposes to
a perk after Bishop g7 efore it
resembles more of a perk White's ideas
Queen d2 Castle queenside go for these
ideas but you don't always see in Kings
and even the other half of the time
black will play d5 and it's no longer a
king's indian structure it's more of a
Greenfeld structure the idea of d5 is to
try and punish the knight on c3 where in
many cases the Knights just misplaced in
this case there's actually a pretty cool
follow up for whites and it's been a
somewhat trendy opening especially among
the top levels idea for why this to play
III Bishop g7 and then h4 now I actually
gave this I did a whole lecture in this
in a st. Louis Chess Club video and they
recorded the whole thing it was part two
till the London the first London video
that I did but they never posted it on
on YouTube but I think they still have
the footage and I went into this or at
least these aligns pretty pretty
extensively and one of the key points in
this line is that if black just ignores
the H plane pushed white is very happy
to play h5 and the position resulting
after nine th I've worked a gauge five
and after all said and done white is
actually just much better here it's a
completely sound sacrifice and black is
just much worse I think if we turn on
stock fish I think it's at least like
plus point eights maybe more yeah plus
one point three so it's usually a pretty
good sign when the computer favours
decide who's down material like whites
down in exchange for a pollen here but
there's so much play ideas with Bishop
d3 queen h2 is a very typical idea too
and then the open H file of course gives
why the fun attack
so yeah that's the general idea for
Kings Indian play I could go much much
deeper but it's just a synopsis I could
also give a recommendation like if if
there's any d4 players out there who
want something simple against King's
Indian I I have a few recommendations
which are slightly off beats but let me
know like if our players out there who
want recommendations for whites against
King's Indian but let's move on let me
keep going here oh I had the notepad
document let me just keep track I'm
gonna start copy pasting things I don't
know if I answered that question fully
but I tried do you know of any books
that make fun of people who constantly
ask for books they will never actually
read um yeah I mean I I will admit that
I don't think I've ever read a least a
chess book from front to back there's a
few books I probably completed most of
like puzzle books but a full chest book
I don't think I've ever read fully just
because there's so much like so much
solar and using the computer especially
the extent of like databases and like
annotated games and video lectures
you don't need chess books to get good
these days um okay
Oh Jay I for one - Joe is asking about
preparation interesting why not prepare
for my next opponent
I'm a Sicilian player how would you
recommend playing against the elephant
variation yeah let's look at that
elephant so I'll open Sicilian for black
I mean I play the L of pain now there's
two different elephant's I think I'm
going to have to ask some follow-up
also ji4 one to Joe do you know your
opponent's online account because if you
do it makes it so much easier to prepare
I hope he's still here but after E 4 C 5
outlook and I assume is C 3 also known
as a C 3 Sicilian and then in this
position black has two moves there's an
ID f6 and there's D 5 both are very
popular very playable we can see the
breakdown both moves have over 10,000
games if you have as chess comm account
there is a there is a tool in chess calm
which is not available in me chess where
you can actually filter through his
games based in the opening it kind of
looks like this it's like an opening
explorer maybe you need the premium
version but it's so powerful for
preparing against players because you
see exactly what lines they go into and
then you kind of you look to target the
lines that they're weakened and more
questions I have to keep up okay so just
gonna paste that in but in terms of like
general alop in lines I can give you two
recommendations personally I play d5
almost exclusively but I will start with
a recommendation in this Knight f6 move
because it's slightly more popular and
there's actually a cool line which tries
to defuse the position really quickly
but I'll have to remember it so e5
Knight d5 how to play the Scotch
candidates oh man okay I'm just gonna
take a moment oh no I want to open that
here let's take a moment and just make
sure I'm not forgetting these questions
we probably won't get to all of them
something simply against Kings Indian
okay I think I got most of them okay
let's stay focused on this so white
usually plays d4 oh yeah we take on d4
Knight of three is Amina I will almost
always delay recapturing because white
just builds a pressure in this pawn is
pinned so black can play knight c6 and
then white will usually take now if
you're going into the sign Bishop c4 is
also a move to know how to play against
I did some preparation like at some
point where I prepared Knight b6 Bishop
b3 and then this kind of offbeat moved
g6 but if we look at the stats here g6
is the third most popular move but one
of the most highest or one of the
highest-scoring moves for for black with
idea that you want to play Bishop g7
castle and then d6 and you have serious
pressure against white center pawns so
for example just play through the main
line let's say Knight c3 I think d6 here
or even d5 but g6 looks a bit more
direct so that's what I would say that's
against Bishop c4 but main line is he
take t4 Oh actually both are I mean
they're almost equally as popular but
see take t4 I think is maybe played a
bit more often and then key move t6 now
in this position yeah white usually
plays Bishop c4 if I remember correctly
Knight c3 is a mistake it's important
like when you're studying openings you
want to look at maybe a few responses
from your opponent in each position like
know which moves are bad and so on and
shadow check crypt own who I actually
met a few days ago I was in San
Francisco for the protest League pretty
epic event also meant who else I met a
lot of people there like the whole chess
comm staff I met Nathan F another leech
a streamer met a few of the best poker
players in the world
Safa Cara Nakamura
recently what did he recently do
recently double adopted me but let's not
get into that might see three's a
mistake because not because of night
takes III I take C 3 is a big mistake
I've seen this trap where black tries to
get good structure and then runs into d5
and this is just crushing for whites but
if not just simply takes first promote
variation
let me annotate this to just so people
know what they're looking at
do you take e5 good move Knight c3 is
jus Vyas so after D take e5
I mean blacks just getting better
structure if t take e5 you can take on
c3 Queen take ta I assume they take to
Yates and this is just a good position
for black let's go back the mean um yeah
the mean line is Bishop c4 and now the
line I recommend here for black is to
play a lesser pocket remove Knight b6 is
the main line I've been very intrigued
with this move detaii 5 which has been
played just a just under 400 times out
of maybe over 3,000 games the point of
this move is to go for trades and this
black you're you're actually looking
just to trade everything off after a
detaii 5 there's another cool move
Knight DB for and now I thought the
mainlines Queen take T 8 I guess Queen V
3 is also a move let's stick with Queen
take 2 eggs and I take d8 now I'm not
going to go too much further in this
position but I will say that it's it's a
somewhat rich position there's many
different positional ideas and one of
the overall ideas of playing this
against a low pin is to get a more
positional game because a lot of the
elephant players like more aggressive
lines where they keep Queens on the
board so if you can get a more
positional middle game trade Queens
early I think black has good chances to
to play for for a win here or at least
hold a draw and against a stronger
player this is a good way to neutralize
so I would recommend take a look at like
some of the GM games from this position
both remove Queen b3 I don't think I've
looked at which maybe I should've but II
6 looks natural Castle and the thing to
note about this sort of structure is
this pawn it gains space for a white but
it's also potentially weak now there's a
move here for Black Knight a5 and the
score is nice like okay a lot of draws
but white doesn't really win too many
games and that's what you want from the
black side this should be fine check so
some trades cleaning it for mine seems
pretty forcing then you just bring on a
knight back you have this nice d5 square
for the Knights so I don't I don't think
I'm gonna go too much further but I hope
that gives you some quick insight like
the lines that were covered they're just
a starting point but sometimes that's
the most difficult thing is to get like
a recommendation like to to know what to
dig into more deeply so hopefully that's
of some value I'm missing a lot of
comments here it's really hard to like
stay focused on one position and keep up
with the comments that's why I'm copying
copying and pasting should have copied
that user names too
any quick questions should I focus on a
single book at a time or can I study
multiple books you can study multiple
books I think it's very rare to work
through a book like just one book front
to back without looking at any other
books like chess is a game there's so
many different layers to it and
especially if you're if you actively
play in tournaments you don't
necessarily want to be studying one
thing over kind of an extended period of
time you want to have some balance so
like do a book for tactics - a book for
maybe going over a higher level game
if you use books to study openings but
also take advantage of the online
resources too because those can be
pretty valuable I just want to read the
comment from ji 401 - okay he was
heading to bed today for the last oh
happy birthday
nice well that's your birthday gift some
some prep and Allison
someone's playing a chess 960 this
evening do I have any tips for that
follow opening principles in chess960
it's so important or it's so easy to
forget about like basic principles like
development King safety control the
center but then like when you get into
the middle game of course like chess
tactics and strategy apply another tip
I'll say which is really important for
chess960 it's also really important in
chess in general is finding harmony for
the pieces in most chess openings pieces
develop pretty fluidly like nice come
towards the center the bishops have a
few options and some chess960 positions
it's very hard to find harmony
especially with the minor pieces so
sometimes you want to like take your
time early on just to figure out some
different like harmonious development
schemes so hopefully that's that's of
some purpose or of some value red
samurai says LOL it's late it's actually
still before 10:00 p.m. where I am I'm
in California still so I know the on the
the west coast it's it's easier to stay
up later
Knights Templar how do you play the
French Cecilia what is the French
Sicilian is that C 5 and E 6 what please
elaborate if you're asking about like a
specific opening that maybe isn't common
give me a exact move order I'll paste
that in how to play the Scotch gambit
okay let's make a new chapter on this
how to play the scotch scotch gambit
kind of relies on getting early
initiative best way to play against
someone I've covered the best or what
some recommended ways to play and so
London in the past which I thought were
here but maybe they aren't I I do have a
video on it though I have a video it's
not as popular as some of the other st.
Louis Chess Club videos that I've done
let me find it real quick if you just
type into YouTube black wins against d4
black ones against d4 it should be the
first response there we go
and I give I give away some London
preparation from the black side there's
a really important game with Victor la
Janica playing the black side and if you
learn that game you'll be you'll be good
to go with the London we're playing
against the London so there's that video
let's talk about Scotch gambit briefly
I'm not a special and specialist in this
I've done a video on how to play against
the Scotch gambit as black after d5 I
think black equalizes with a good
position but if it's a true Scotch
gambit black can take you take and then
there's a there's a pretty easy path to
development for a white like Bishop c4
Queen b3
five possibilities from very early on
Bishop g5 possibilities and that's
without recognizing resources and
depending on what black does you you
look for different ways to to attack
from early on I actually don't know too
much theory here there's a bunch of
different ways black can play what I
might recommend is like use ohs settings
to find instructive games or usually
test database so like focus on Blitzen
rapid and classical and maybe keep the
rating the average rating above 2000 and
then if you scroll down here like just
look at games that white has won and
especially like the higher level games
it can be interesting let's view this
game so first random game I picked and
sometimes a tool like chess faces is
better for finding games like this
because you can filter based on rating
and based on a number of moves so
sometimes it's good to look for
miniatures and whatever opening you you
learn or you study because that way you
see how how you could win quickly and
that will give you inspiration white
remain down upon
I'm actually not impressed with this
game quite still down upon but why kept
the pressure like the defiles nice I'm
still not impressed White's still down
upon how did white witness ooh
Bishop versus Knight okay now it's
better it's a bishop just completely out
performance at night in these positions
okay that was an undesirable game let's
look at another one
trying to find a miniature it's another
long game let's look at this one you
just want to find like one nice game
okay let's look at this game Knight g5
interesting
this is not impressive again okay I'm
not gonna spend so much time looking at
scotch gambit games I'd say against
lower level player is it's probably a
very fine effective opening like develop
your pieces look for tactics keep in
mind Queen b3 and Queen 84 ideas and
maybe good things will happen let me go
back to my notepad thing recommendation
for qgd from blacks perspective what you
asked that question
qgd ctrl-f oh here Oh is asking that
question well if you're looking for
recommendation and Queens gambit
declined there's a few there's a few
different move orders you can choose
it's imagine white just plays in normal
stuff like starting in this position you
can play either Bishop e7 or 9s 6 both
of them lead to different things I mean
I play that at 6 as I've been playing it
since childhood
but I know Bishop e7 is pretty popular
among like higher level players it
equalizes if you're like well prepared
I'll give you okay I'll give you one
like fun and very kind of thematic
Queen's Gambit line which at some point
I think it was like one of my secret
novelties but I think it's now like just
a known idea and it happens in like one
of the main structures and maybe you can
use this line as inspiration to like
build a a more effective repertory or
even like just know some some middle
game plan so and the line occurs after
many different move or move orders I
think you can start with Bishop to e7
but essentially it gets some position
like this let's say c6 oops oh wait I
want to open up a new board let's go
back qgt special wait
super-secret qgd line for black ok so if
you play the Queens gambit declined as
black you're probably getting into the
Carlsbad structure a lot which is a
structure resulting from this position
it happens after a Bishop e7 as well and
[Music]
the way the way to understand this
position is to dig very deep you usually
have to study the middle games which
results after the opening so let's keep
going here let's not pay too much
attention to the move order but we'll
focus on positions where white puts
tonight on f3 puts a bishop on d3 and
then castles so some position like this
maybe maybe other players play Queen's
II on the decline you get some position
similar to this and I will admit I
played this type of position for many
years and didn't really know the plan
for black like black develops for the
most part this bishops usually not that
impressive and the question is how do
you like further your position in the
middle game and there's a couple plans
one of the most popular plans is to play
rook e8 followed by 94 like for example
rocky 8's imagine Queen C 294 wait it's
not e for possible now you for is not
possible because H 7 hangs so black
would play this and then 94 an idea is
you're you're not giving away anything
because if take take before as well
defended so this is one way to play I
think this is a very fine way to play
for for black but I see the economy from
here oh he usually plays rook e8 and not
f8 which I like to do too and when I
discovered like this deeper plan behind
neither fades i I realized that like
there's there's a lot of ways for black
to play for an advantage so let's go
with neither fate here promote variation
now a lot of times white will play the
minority attack I go for
rook be one before etc and the eventual
b5 an idea for black is to just kind of
ignore the Queen side and focus on the
Kings side so let's make rook be one the
main line I will note that if white
plays Knight to e5 I think there's a
principled move here to play which is my
chief for if I'm not mistaken and we
trade off a pair of Knights it makes
life slightly easier you just confirm
that with stockfish yeah Knight g4
should be equalizing Bishop to g7 Queen
to e7 okay if Knight f3 is the best move
for white it should be fine
oh so he's ran into Bishop two got six
followed by b4 that's another line I've
actually run into that too and that line
I'll admit I actually haven't studied
too extensively take take b4 let's look
at this as I'm curious too white squares
better in most lines Bishop g4 ism a
move oh let's look at masters Bishop g4
so black actually does okay here and
Kasparov has played this I mean it's
part of his play this is black I might
as well just use this game has kind of a
skeleton let's insert okay so Bishop g4
yeah I remember like Bishop e7 Bishop d6
is very common because this Bishop is
just misplaced on f6 yeah sorry it will
get two other questions later but this
is interesting for me at least
Bishop d6 okay white plays Bishop f5
sometimes when you find a game like this
you you want to like you want to find
the find how it branches out so just
don't just look what happened in the
game look at alternatives especially
from your opponent's side so let's
imagine b5 here
there's this interesting move rookie six
I would you sock fish to like see how
stock fish plays Queen h4 Wow and sock
fish likes to attack g3 and then not not
Queen h3 between h5 interesting and
sometimes what I like to do is just play
again stock fish I'm not going to allow
uh links and the chats yeah thank you
appreciate that uh the time out anyway a
queen h5 what was I saying oh yeah when
you're starting positions like this
especially from a game sometimes just
play against stock fish see how it
continues and then rather than like
passively just playing through the top
stock fish recommendation when you play
against it you can better internalize
the ideas and hopefully that's that's
more helpful but I want to show okay I
want to show my super-secret line which
is after neither fades maybe hero has
seen this before because he studies I
think he studies chess a decent amount
one so the overall plan for black is
turn on suckish if we know the stock
fish likes this position but if you use
my plan then not my plan but if you use
the main plan in position stock fish
will eventually change its mind so the
idea for black is to play Bishop d6 and
then h6 and we're getting the bishop
here and we play Bishop d6 first so we
make it that the Queen can recapture on
f6 and the bishop is on a better square
on d6 Oh school takes most of your free
time ouch well my condolences but after
B for a6 from me thrown in the gay six
is useful we make white play for the
idea is when white plays b5 we can take
and the a file is open that's of some
value for a black
but now that can play Bishop d6 b5 the
slide flows very nicely all of the moves
are pretty flow flowing here after h6
Bishop take f6 Queen take f6 take take
and now there there looks like a really
attractive move for whites which is e
for me floor looks like a very difficult
move to deal with because Y would be
threatening e5 and then a pawn to e4
tonight a key for it just looks bad for
black but there's a really cool move in
this position and what I learned this
line I became became comfortable learn
or I became comfortable playing these
these Queens gambit declined lines as
black just because of this next move so
the move is Knight f4 which is kind of a
pea sacrifice but not really because
after a five looks like blacks just
getting a forked and losing a bishop but
then very nice move Queen e6 idea being
after pawn takes Bishop there's queen g4
and this is just like really nice for
black or at least equalizing I forget
the exact valuation I think like
slightly better if I remember correctly
and white has to be very careful because
I move like g3 loses immediately take
take game over so I think white only has
one move 91 and then rook to e1 wait
hero is asking stuff hold on if black
plays Bishop d6 can Y play Bishop take
g6 oh yeah we can get to that actually
let's go back for a moment wait after
Bishop d6 and then h6 yeah after h6 we
don't take on g6 we take on g5 I've
actually had a good number of games from
this position
white retreats and then we can play g4
and then plans of g6 King g7 rotate
shades and then you have the H file and
these are fun positions to play and you
get the bishop hair yeah so the main
line after 91 rook to e1 White has this
move f3 and here I think I'll just cheat
with stockfish is it a draw no it's not
a draw
rook take F on Bishop take a foreign
Queen g5 the analysis can keep going or
Queen e6 even better than you in the
pawn and black actually wanna pawn
somehow so this is very playable and
just good for black very differently
drag queen g4 no this is just better for
luck I think the other line is if Y
plays I move like 92 but then black can
take on d3
Queen take and then Bishop f8 or Bishop
a6 first there's your basics first looks
nice Queen c2 Bishop f8 and it's two
bishops versus two knights this pollen
looks backwards maybe c5 will happen at
some points and if the position opens up
the two bishops should be preferable
okay let's spend a lot of time on that
but hopefully if there's any Queens
gambit declined players or anyone just
looking for a response against d4 I
think if you if you play this line like
black find some nice harmony with the
pieces especially this 9 f8 to g6 idea
it's pretty nice but of course it's just
a starting point and good night to hero
thanks for watching thanks for asking
questions let's move on let's let's try
and answer some other questions I'm
scrolling up here which tirage French
trash yeah there's a lot of trashes in
chess I hope I didn't lose all the
viewers from just showing a queen's
gambit declined
position scroll up even further I also
have my notepad document Scott you know
the Queen's gamesclient
oh yeah I was gonna show something
simple against Kings Indian steam 19 is
lurking but loving the stream okay
thanks Dee 19 thanks for making yourself
known if there's any other lurkers here
who have questions don't be afraid to
ask there's no penalty for asking a bad
question
just keep it chest related also what do
I want to say I don't know what I wanted
to say o Knight c3 g3 again Sicilian
police from the white cider for the
black side favorite French lines from
black quickly show the first 10 moves oh
you want me to show you the first 10
moves from this position if anyone wants
to go back and look at the study you can
access everything that I've gone over at
this link so hopefully that helps I
don't know what excellent it is asking
Oh unless ok he's asking about close
Sicilian with Knight c3 and g3 when I
started playing the closed Sicilian I
didn't play it as like a Grand Prix I
played it as as a true closest Union
which is like g3 Bishop g2 d3 and then
it depends what white wants to do like
92 f4 Bishop e3 something like this
Oh our exes is here yeah I'm getting
ready for the title arena yeah shout out
to Oryx who was the one who asked me if
I wanted to do the commentary for titled
arena I do have to get sleep tonight so
we're not going to make this too long
but I'm looking forward to it tomorrow
should be fun I want to do some research
on like all the
top players who might have a chance of
performing well what does I want to say
about this position yeah so it's a
simple setup for lights it's the type of
opening you don't really need to know
too much theory you just know the setup
and you can play it excellent it you
want to know some mill game fans for
white in this opening okay so here's
what we're gonna do we're gonna go to
google and type in short Hossein closed
sicilian hopefully a pop slurp yes this
game this is a very first game I played
through and it's such a good game this
better be the game yes okay so I'm just
gonna add this as a new chapter we chest
is great and the way you can just paste
the chess games URL into the study and
it just imports the game such a good
feature and I think what I'll do I'll
just play through this game like this is
a game you should know by heart and if I
ever do like another lecture for st.
Louis chess club for their their games
you should know by heart lecture I would
show this game because it's so good it's
just kind of long though it's only 34
moves okay so white does the setup
nothing special so far Queen d2
it's important to note that if you're
playing this sort of setup okay I see
there's questions if you're playing the
setup you delight f4 because you want to
keep the option of Bishop to h6 open
oops this is the one thing I don't like
about the study the study interface
maybe orwicz could actually implement a
feature I think he's a developer when
you scroll it like zooms through with
the moves and because I'm using a
trackpad
I accidentally scroll all the time so
it'd be great if we could like turn that
off but yeah as white you don't play f4
too early because you you sometimes want
to play Bishop h6 because the trade of
arts red bishops from a positional
standpoint can help whites that weakens
the King side a little bit
so he's asking should you let black gain
space on the queenside
the answer as we'll see in this game is
yes you you completely ignore blacks
queenside advanced black usually goes
for some plan like b5 and b4
there are cases where you could throw in
a four but sometimes a four is just met
with a six and then a four can be
weakening for white in certain ways so
sometimes you just allow B Phi P for
which happens in the game B 592 and now
94 and this is very common setup for
black just using the d4 square it's in
blacks control white castle's ecigs and
now this is such a cool idea from Nigel
Schwartz where he understands is the
this knight on d4 it's a decent piece
but it's also potentially a target in
the center and it's not technically an
outpost because white has a future idea
of c3 so in this game we'll see what I
actually prepare is c3 and a pretty nice
way and the move here it's hard to
understand just by looking at it is
might see one but what white is doing is
trading off or preventing any trading
off of the night so this and I can't
trade itself off and the simple plan is
night t1 and then C 3 and when white
plays C 3 then you kind of take over
control of the one square that black is
is controlling in this position and
that's kind of what happens 19 197 and
c3 taketake the knight has two retreats
and when the knight retreats the setup
for black is not that harmonious because
the Knights kind of get in the way of
each other now the one thing yeah the
bishop has some scope along the diagonal
but we'll see what happens
Bishop h6 is white just wants to trade
and black can't really prevent the trade
of bishops Bishop f6 just looks wrong so
black just castles take take
and now white redevelops the Knights
without having to worry about the d4
square so 93 black Daisy 592 Bishop a6
and this is a classic double edge
position where black wants to play on
the Queen side white wants to play on
the Kings side so well I whites play is
very simple just like expand with f4 and
potentially i-5 that's what short starts
out with at the same time it's important
for a white to minimize blacks play on
the on the Queen side I have added the
scroll toggle to our backing to our
backlog wait what does backlog mean does
that mean you're gonna implement the
feature so that would be really cool um
sweet oh I have a few other feature
requests for bug requests but I'll maybe
maybe later let's get through this game
rook AC one really important move
because what black wanted to do here is
Queen b6 and Queen B - what rook c1 does
is it just aims to put the rook on c2
and then it kills any counter play that
black in generates so after this just
rook C - everything's defended there's
really no penetration for black rook b7
was playing and then really nice move
this bishops not doing anything so why
not improve it Bishop h3 Bishop e6 think
at this point why it's already doing
very well and blacks like put all the
pieces on the side but has no real like
way of making progress
rook b1 another nice move Knight c1
let's kill the counter play this is
common like when you're attacking
sometimes you kill the counter play and
then then go through with your own
attack h4 h4 is a nice move because I
assume h5 we run into f5 and things fall
apart
five to two oh yeah so black sack the
exchange for some play but it just
completely didn't work because white was
so active and had more material and the
D file was a big problem for black yeah
it's just over at this point so this is
just one game it made a big impact on me
especially like this whole night see one
night t1 maneuver which looks super
passive but turned out to be really good
and when you're learning this opening
the way you learn about the middle game
plans is to find games by strong players
especially in this line like look at the
other Nigel short gains you should be
able to go to like chess games calm and
just type in Nigel short clothes
Sicilian and find a bunch of games that
he's played in this line oh I just
rolled up to read a question from that
BEM dog one and he's asking where'd you
go to study openings so I just gave you
one resource chess games calm but Lee
chess Lee chess has a great opening
database the one downside is you only
get access to the top the top four games
in any given position maybe this is
something else that arcs can add to that
backlog is have a more searchable game
feature this is where chess base
performs a bit better where you can
actually filter through games and and
find not only fine games from a specific
player but find matchups like sometimes
while I enjoy most is finding a
collection of games in an opening let's
say closed Sicilian where there is a
very strong grandmaster against someone
rated below 2200 and then you see how
like grandmasters will consistently
outplay people in in a particular
opening and this is great if you're like
if you're at an expert level you're
consistently playing people around your
own level
if you see how how people around your
own level lose pretty brutally against
jeans it's a good thing to study okay
some people are leaving um wait who's
leaving Oh our ex is leaving okay see
you oh but he know that my my request
that's cool just 365 is yeah I mean
there's a lot of sites which have like
opening databases
there's also database chess face.com
that's the link where you can actually
search like you can do more customizable
searches okay I see there are some more
questions I just have to take a break
from talking like my mouth is beginning
to hurt does this say can people read
this it's big enough to read this is my
grandma's mug a big wine fan anyway I'm
gonna go up and take a moment just a
copy-paste some questions oh did that
guy elaborate on French Sicilian because
I forget French Sicilian I'm also a very
slow reader so sometimes it takes me
like several seconds to read like just a
short paragraph I should copy and paste
so user names - I've noticed you've
played the G for gambit in the London
system oh ho that line oh that's an
unsound line let me just show that real
quick I will tell a back story from that
what should I tell the backstory yeah
it's probably not gonna happen
initial position G for London touch this
is just like a hybrid of like a bunch of
weird openings
yeah this is I'm debating whether to
show this cause like this is something
I've never used in tournaments I've used
it a few times online but I was actually
preparing it for a pretty serious
tournament I'll show it because it's
such a rare thing but it probably will
never happen but I do have a line I was
preparing it for existing in in Denmark
over the summer maybe the people who are
like huge fans of me have seen the game
that I played against him because I gave
a lecture and st. Louis chess club and I
went over that game extensively I ended
up beating him in the London
he played something else he played like
Knight of 6 Bishop f4 he played
something I wasn't expecting but the
main preparation I did for him was a 6
on move one and it was weird like he's a
26 he's over 2,600 feet a very strong
grandmaster many many games in the
database when I like compiled all his
tournament games and all the games I
could find he only had one game in the
London is that true it either one or
zero games in London and one of the only
things I could find was when he was
playing like e6000 my main preparation
for him I spent maybe a couple hours
before the game like the night before
preparing this line Bishop f4 f5 and
then g4 and oh is this Ben at this this
is occurred before oh not bad he's
played this so the recent that's 2016
don't know if I saw that game yeah g4 is
not a novelty but it's such a rare line
where I had to use a lot of computer
analysis kind of figuring out if this is
a sound thing to go into and then
them the most expected lines would be
and I concluded that it's actually
pretty dangerous for black and even the
flack is somewhat prepared it's still
like a sound gambit especially if black
takes a pawn h3 can be pretty venomous
and there's all these lines it's kind of
like a kingside banco where if pawn to
h3 let's just turn on stock fish on
Knight c3 immediately
I mean White has so many ideas like
before I should take a Sharia Knight to
h3 and the fact that the H file opens
it's um it's nice for black or for
whites I should say so I just wanted to
share there was some really weird things
I were weird lines I was preparing I
think one line was when black plays g3
but then just bishop take g3 and then
Bishop g2 comes this is good for uh for
whites another really funny line I was
preparing because I knew existing is a
very creative player I thought maybe he
would play a creative move here and that
if we see the second recommended move
for black is to play g5 and my
preparation was to play Bishop c1 Bishop
e5 I think is playable but I think
bishops he wants the strongest move and
I'll just turn off stockfish cuz the
next move for black is just ridiculous
but it's also very playable is to play
h5 I remember preparing this I I looked
at this line for maybe 10 or 20 minutes
I was just kind of laughing to think how
anyone could get a position like this
after four moves in like a high level
game but I thought I thought this would
be a likely likely position or maybe
somewhat possible position maybe not
likely but it wouldn't be beyond
possibility so anyway I think I was
prepared further here I think the
preparation was to take and then play
something that Knight c3 and okay these
pawns are just overextended so
anyway that's the story about g4 I will
say g4 doesn't work as well in other
lines like if black plays at five
immediately and then doesn't play e6 but
plays like d6 or Knight f6 I think I
played this against crew 64 yesterday
though I played g4 year oh I played this
against infinite flash chess - if we go
to the opening Explorer we might find
both games yeah this game way there's
only two games no oh maybe this side it
was a simultaneous oh maybe that didn't
make it into the the database we can
insert this game as crew 64 still
watching because if he is I don't want
to like prepare in front of him but
anyway um he took which I don't think is
a great move because it allows e4 and
then he played d5 I mean to be fair this
was bullets and I play e5 yeah it was
just good for whites then somehow I lost
oh by the way I'm currently competing
against 364 in a Twitter poll has moobot
been promoting it about where are you
oh maybe moobot hasn't been promoting it
I'm here the shamelessly promote this
Twitter poll I would HIGHLY appreciate
anyone who votes for me in this poll
there's money online
it's from the chest comm tournament
earlier today but if I win the poll
there's money currently I'm I think I'm
in second place
maybe that's changed a Twitter
twitter twitter the later it gets some
more easily i get like completely
sidetracked and distracted but real
quick real quick twitter file me and
that's very slow or it's just lagging i
know what's going on
o twitter is not resizing okay i'm gonna
resize wow it's so slow okay
i think people can see that this is a
Twitter poll I have thirty nine percent
to 40 percent even if you're a crew 64
fan he has no chance of winning so I
need all the votes I can get anyway I
don't want to spend all or any more time
on that but just gotta give a right hook
just to spread some love but anyway back
to back to this Oh infinite flash wants
to go over our game
Esther Chen how can we ask questions you
can ask questions in the chat to desk to
try and ask a question I don't think he
did oh he just voted though I appreciate
that yeah let's go over the infinite
flash game open this in a new tab and my
computer is it's been over eating a lot
so I don't want to destroy my computer
before tomorrow
hello rainbows guy
thank you Sarah b @b h XD for voting Oh
another question from IO Jay
wait I think I've copied and pasted his
question twice if I paste your question
and you don't have to repeat it
thanks for moderating I don't know what
I missed
Thank You rx yeah let's talk about this
game so I played infinite flash chess
who's another streamer who I know in
person and I know he likes to play the
Dutch so I play them in the Dutch can I
flip the board yeah okay
f5 Bishop f4 Knight f6 and I was feeling
spicy it was actually really late at
night it was like after midnight Pacific
time and I was tired and I didn't want
to play a classical game and when I
started the game I was just kind of a
joke to join the style then I ended up
staying staying awake for several hours
to finish this game
maybe it wasn't several hours maybe I
was like 90 minutes but still felt like
a long time so I played g4 and one thing
I noticed because I was watching
infinite flashes chess stream and he was
he I think he was overestimating my play
he just assumed that my moves were
strong but I think he had a very good
position middle game like he called my
Bluffs with his moves like he just took
the pawn d5 I think was good I thought
black was doing pretty well um wait
what's the best move for black here whoa
I don't want to do that what's the best
move for black is it might take g4 then
he for od6 mmm
actually didn't know that h3 what just
happened that was weird
we're weary night AG for e for d6 h3 I'm
just curious this is one of those
moments I'm just playing again stockfish
because I it looks like White has good
compensation take take Oh 96 ok maybe
not
9 f3 I'm still playing in stock fish I'm
just using the or playing the black
moves as stock fish and then playing the
light was as myself he wants to play c6
yeah I guess box up upon e 5 is nice but
it doesn't really do much ok let's go
back and let's see what happened the
game yeah I think this whole c5 thing
was firing knight c6 will turn off stock
fish I was trying to build a pressure
I see the computer already now analyze
this maybe I can turn that one off there
we go nice um yeah bishop before I see
if the computer says it was a mistake oh
space plays that engine move really Oh
space also turns on the engine that's
cool so it's like chess base nice
keyboard shortcuts are the best so the
common station for why is the fact that
i'm castled these pawn the ibaka center
pawns but there's like a 3e for ideas
this Queen exerts pressure it's all
pretty hopeful and like objectively box
just better the Black has to play
accurately
wait what oh yeah I play Bishop g5 you
played Bishop before and then I played
Knight e4 which I thought was a clever
move
wait now how do I turn the engine off
from here cuz it's on doesn't give me
the toggle RX RX needs to help me cuz I
crest face it turned on that engine but
there's no more toggle when I go here
it's already disabled maybe I can enable
it and then disable it there we go
I think that's a bug when you press
space it leaves out the toggle until I
turn off in line notation there we go
okay so now we're back to normal
okay so 94 I thought was clever
cuz it attacks this and it takes
advantage of this pin and this pin but
he just plays Bishop f5 and then after
Knight G 3 Bishop g6 I play e4 yeah he
shouldn't castle you should just play
like Bishop e7 maybe looks ok yeah oh
maybe I'll add a few more months um who
wants to be a mod infinite flash chests
you can be a mom I'm not gonna not
everyone any more mods fake can be Ahmad
Rx is already a mod um anyone else find
no in person if I've met you in person
make yourself known in the chat I'm
always curious like who I've met in
person I know there's maybe some lurkers
watching it yeah the mod for the
infinite flash chest is long overdue
I'm not gonna mod c-bro and don't worry
anyway I'm just gonna show it happened
because I thought up like still had like
decent compensation here but he got low
in time and the ending to this game was
really interesting because there is some
mating attack which did not actually end
in mates and I was just playing this
kind of off intuition I assumed there
should be something but this was crazy
I'm actually curious to check with the
engine here does it seem like there
should be some force mate like all of
whites pieces have potential to attack
the king I wanted to do something like
94 at some point but it doesn't quite
work or even like rook take t5 I was
fantasizing about like this is 94 I
think the reason why I didn't play that
is because King take d5 like how do you
made the King so I I found a way to win
like I required playing some eventual
quiet move 94 it was a nice move because
if he takes I take here king b5 so crazy
I had to just go for material and then
it's just enough to him I was happy with
Queen d5 nice move
what's idea why oh yeah I defend against
b3 and then Rock a4 is unstoppable I
just want to go back and use an engine
in this position and he made
no mates which is better position mmm oh
wow
Bishop III I'm worse it's equal I'm
better stock fish is not a very decisive
creature but only slightly better this
is crazy with blacks King on c5 how can
ye be slightly better now it's equal
wait he didn't take on e4 I thought
taking on e4 losses take Wow
King b5 I'm black survives that's
ridiculous because White's King is also
unsafe and really it's only my queen
attacking I think he probably just
assumes that this is losing but wow yeah
I assumed I could just like take
something here like take here but this
just goes into some kind of endgame or
even black has chances that's crazy
let's box up a pawn
okay that's cool um yeah I might end it
very soon I'm tired but I know someone
repeated their question twice are you
still here i oj 12 I'll repeat my
question what can people see this well
people can see that nice okay so uh how
would you study the middlegame for more
obscure openings like bloomenfeld seems
like the engine never favors black
that's what it seems hard to understand
if you're gonna use an engine test
opening you should play the opposite
side so if you're studying like
Blumenfeld for black have the engine
play is black and you play white and you
play natural moves and you see that how
the engine beats you that's one that's
one strategy the other strategy is to
find games
I guess we're using Blumenfeld as an
example there's many players who many
like high-level players who've played
Blumenfeld with decent success
it's a tricky opening and I think if you
can find games and sometimes the best
strategy when you find games don't just
like passively like play through the
games like click through the moves and
just like observe but try and actively
guess the moves from the black side and
flying games up that black one there's
many tools to do that online to just
search for games in a certain opening
and if you're actively guessing through
the moves it'll better stick with you
you'll better internalize ideas um oh
the other thing I was gonna say about
Blumenfeld I have a friend who uses a
bloomenfeld together as like Grandmaster
title it was a pretty cool a cool result
for him he he played the bloomenfeld
against - was it - super geum's no he
drew Vidya goth who's over 2700 he had a
black better position is back in the
Blumenfeld and then he beat Sokolov was
with
to clinch the the title like he got this
final I am norm so if anyone's
interested in those games especially
whoever asked a question who I don't
think is still here
but maybe he can watch the stream or the
replay I'm gonna go back to Google Andre
Kevon so close oh come on
Ches maybe here we go yes sometimes
there will be other popular people with
the same name we have to include Ches so
this is one game in the bloomenfeld I'll
let people just play through this but
black somehow found a way to win against
the strong GM and then the other game
was Andre against VDU I think he had
good chances to win you guys here we go
oh maybe the opening wasn't so good but
like later on like black had chances
esta Chang would you be willing to look
at one of my games I'm trying to obtain
the PGN right now I'm really really
tired I'm gonna do more streams like
this though because I think it's
valuable for the viewers it's not just
me playing games but it's answering your
specific questions and hopefully you
guys can gain some value from it what
else do I want to say oh I also want to
fake thank everyone for the follows draw
Meister 2017 Polyface 7 Kayne Smurf pre
commander Breivik Colorado x7o b1 Jacoby
something Charlie checkmate thank you
everyone
I
j12 ace 1886 chess at least the list
keeps going but I appreciate all the
viewership I know there's questions I
didn't get to but I'm gonna end it there
okay one last question any advice to get
from 2,000 to 2,200 to get to master
level you have to be consistently
playing players above master level
because that's how you'll learn although
mod um best books again I don't
recommend books but I shared a link
earlier it's a perpetual chess podcast
I'll share this link again it's a like
great list of book recommendations
okay I'm ending it there oh maybe I
conveyed someone let's raid someone
liquor mark orlova chess oh and James
son oh this is such a conflicting thing
I want to raid both of them
James son I'm gonna raid James son uh
he's crypto net him in person in wait a
minute in San Francisco wait can I
Sheriff I can wait a minute I'm gonna do
something I've never done before this is
supposed to be a leech a stream I just
want to share like a few photos from
this event that was sponsored by twitch
it was a really cool chess event maybe
people can see Lightroom because it's
just sharing the display
let's go like five star photos oh I
didn't write them
yeah this is just like the the past
weekend this what this is why I wasn't
streaming I was just like witnessing a
really cool chess event in person people
were playing online and like players
from all over the world from china
armenia armenian to winning this and I
was there as like a photographer and I
was doing reporting for us chess it was
pretty cool so one of the top players
from China Wang Yu Wei who ended up not
doing that that great for his team
though they did finish in 2nd and the
Chinese team and this was a celebration
anyway I just wanted to share a few
photos from that I might do a future
extremes where I just like edit photos
because that's another passion of mine
but anyway yeah let's raid uh let's raid
crypt own it's been a long day uh great
Krypton okay I'm taking off I will be
here tomorrow for the the Li chest
titled arena I'm doing commentary it's
official we chess commentary it should
be really cool it's tomorrow at noon
pacific time Magnus Carlsen Carlsen
should be playing it's going to be epic
so stay tuned for that and go watch
Crypt own good bye